indeed we say some moves made
grandmasters feel like little kids this
was one of them actually this one made
us feel like idiots when the move landed
on the board we were like what night of
six wesley i know it wasn't the greatest
day that you've had in history certainly
uh you you play better but this game
right here knight f6 take us through the
moment that you understood
that he would be in such a bind that
he'd never get out of your threads yeah
i'm very happy about this game
especially the the move knight f6 uh
it's not often that you see
if you sacrifice a rook and it works
perfectly
uh the thing is he's knight and bishop's
very passive if bishop would prefer to
be in a dark square
and i was just so happy to get through
the knight six king h8 but i have queen
c2 ideas in any case so he has to take i
wasn't completely sure if it was winning
i mean i'm pretty sure it was winning
but
of course i couldn't calculate
everything well the engines at first
thought maybe it's not so great when you
the way you played i think queen 86 but
they caught on soon enough that this was
actually much deeper and not a bad move
we were confused the engines were
confused again i want to understand when
did you first like just appreciate this
just works
yeah when i when i saw b when you look
at the position we see bishop on e8
knight on d8 also the queen is strapped
in the corner on a8
then
black's king doesn't really have much
defenders basically all he has is
knights the rook doesn't really
participate in the game
so when when you just see black's pieces
very passively um also h4 and rook h3 is
coming very quickly
and bishop sit there also and black
really lacks the dark square defense so
work me through this i mean are the
engine's saying question mark but as
soon as you move it's gonna say yeah
you're winning but
when you when you are back two moves
before this we can just go back to the
night right here like yeah the night
drops back which looks like a real
mistake not helping out but
97 winning back the exchange looks so
natural you're gonna have the two
bishops anyway and play yeah
what what made your eyes actually look
at knight f6 how did what's the process
for finding such a move uh is it just
the pieces look bad so i should have a
killer blow yeah yeah the pieces look
bad uh black star square's very weak he
doesn't have any defenders on the king
really and once you calculate a few
lines and you see it's very dangerous
you just gotta make that move right it
doesn't doesn't happen
uh every day that you have such such a
move i think also remind me of my game
with magnus in the world championship
match where i had bishop h6 or something
in one game
uh but
yeah the thing is like if i play knight
e7 and grab the rook
then white is better but it's not so
easy because knight takes queen takes
he's got nice v5 and he consolidates so
so you were dissatisfied that this
wasn't giving you what you wanted yeah
that's true i mean this still why it's
better but it's very complex so
when you see a move like m6 and you see
you don't lose right away you have some
ideas uh it's not easy for black to
defend
you just got to
gotta make that move also
yeah black's pieces on the dark square
on the background all very passive but i
have some ideas like this actually like
even before i played
uh b5 i was thinking some h4 h586 ideas
and then knight f6 later so i was
already like after b5 i expected him to
play knight e5 f4
then knight d7 f5
and then after his knight moves anywhere
c5 i play f6
and this should be winning so the dark
squares were already on your mind yeah i
mean so that's exactly i already had
this f6 idea the point but actually like
later on i was completely winning but i
made it much much harder like i should
have
other ways to win so after knight d8
knight f6 gf6 uh yeah queen h6 i thought
queen h6 looks very natural no it's a
good news don't worry about it the
engine is just having a blip moment
yeah it's infused as we were but the
more we looked at it the more we
realized this game is is over queen of
six was another brilliant idea and it
just gets worse and worse and you push
your h pawn on the board yeah the
basically
king king is stuck also like
uh don't know like i'm not even sure if
h4 is the best move i also have e4 set
up h4
also it's interesting
because if it takes i have bishop g4
very hard to defend for black
how about that dark square bishop on the
diagonal isn't it yeah yeah and then the
king can't move
like after e4 i think he has to play c5
in order to block the dark swords with
knight d4 but then
yeah i'm not sure maybe some h4
or
well what you did was so crushing i yeah
i let him escape actually like i was
expecting bishop b5 i should play h3 i
think h5 was fine actually was h5 yeah
h5 was fine i think the moment that you
missed that's like the easier one is
that black's actually not moving this
knight from g7 so if you just take the
bishop take no i thought take takes you
can play rook c8
yeah i think you can now take this
knight no they group e8
i thought yeah i was yeah i was thinking
a long time whether to go for this or
not
a bishop c2 knight g7 maybe you start
with rook h3 just to keep the bind yeah
that's true yeah i was hesitating a long
time whether to go for this but the end
i just went for the piece but he had
three points but all he spawns the king
fighter weak i mean
you call it uh
you call it you made it harder but you
never let go of the win you still
were always winning there was no moment
where suddenly he's back in the game and
he's fighting well in the very end until
he let me checkmate him
which was a nice checkmate too which was
also a nice checkmate well thanks thanks
for joining us we know you had uh you
have to get your rest yeah brilliant
game thank you so much for giving us
some insight into a move like knight to
f6 and we look forward to seeing you
tomorrow thank you